hi I'm Kelly Slater I'm a professional
Surfer and I'm here to answer questions
from Twitter this is surfing support
[Music]
all right first up Ian attack asks how
to wets its work does your whole body
stay dry or what does it get a little
bit wet I need a scientist basically it
just keeps the water between the wetsuit
and your body warm you can actually last
a long time the wetsuits are really good
now the materials are good it's actually
remarkable how cold the water people can
surf in on the East Coast people
regularly surf in the wintertime and 30
something degree water almost freezing
so I mean you can surf right down to
when it's ice or you can just pee in it
and that makes you warm Jay Rodriguez
piano asks actually an absurd amount of
Surfers in the water
I don't know how they know whose turn it
is to get the wave unspoken rules of
surf this is a complex equation we have
like a hierarchy at each break if you've
lived there for a long time
put your time in in the water it's like
your neighborhood knowledge of the wave
aggression skill all of those things
kind of thrown in the mix occasionally
that pecking order gets kind of thrown
off in somebody's super aggressive and
it'll just take a wave we call that
snaking someone or they'll drop it in
front of someone just we call it
dropping in if you're a grommet a little
kid you basically got to sit at the back
of the line you don't get much anything
you sit inside and catch small waves
Evan J Conrad asks so our surfing
competitions like who's having the best
time or something there's not really a
way to objectively judge surfing because
waves are different heights different
lengths there's different maneuvers you
can do different number of maneuvers you
can do with different difficulty for
each one your timing the power your
Technique all these different things
create like a dynamic sort of score in a
judge's mind Canon tree asks how does
Surfers stick to their boards like that
we have wax we have a sticky wax that we
put on our boards in fact the waxes now
have gotten so sticky that some people
when they use them for the first time
say it's too sticky because their feet
don't move but that's what we like
especially when we're doing big
Maneuvers or errors or pushing really
hard in carves using all our power and
and weight next one opayasa asks I have
a surfing question when the surf report
says waste high waves whose waste are
you talking about I'm 5'2 my waist's a
lot lower than most people's just
wondering thanks there's different
scales of surfing in Hawaii if we say
three feet the waves are head high in
Florida if it's head high we say six to
seven feet I think the Hawaiian scale
actually came from the size of the
swells in the ocean that's my best guess
because if you have a a 10 foot swell in
the ocean with a 15 second interval
between the waves the waves are going to
be about 20 feet on the big ones Miss
Alexandria 8 says why does my stepdad
insist on having so many surfboards he's
the only one in my house who surfs
different boards for different waves
it's really like horses for courses for
a tiny wave you kind of need a board
that has more flotation and surface area
for for planing out the bigger the wave
you actually need less surface area but
you need a bigger board that paddles
faster to catch it depending on how big
it gets there's a lot of intricate
things about surfboards different
numbers of fins size of fins the width
the the curve it's an addiction that's
the answer the Goku 57s why do surfers
say Hang Ten with the 10 never do to you
that's actually funny
oh it's ten toes if you're naked it's 11
but never mind Kevin Sawyer asks
searching for the best waves do you have
a secret surf spot I have a lot of
secret surf spots I just don't talk
about them that's why they're called
Secret
for me it's super fun to look at old
satellite imagery and find secret spots
and I want to be able to go back through
different times of year and different
images that were shot because most waves
are seasonal there's going to be
different swell indicators and if you go
back through year after year after year
on satellite imagery you can start to
find strange places in this world where
waves break I'll tell you a place where
there's a lot of secret waves Namibia
there's a ton of waves there but uh good
luck getting to them Tito Tia Marie asks
how does Surfers get hurt they just fall
in the water
go try it there's a million ways you can
get hurt we could probably put up a
montage of wipeouts where guys get
injured I actually have broken my feet
four times on the board from the wave
hitting the board back at me in a
certain way I broke all five metatarsals
across across the top of my foot did a
Liz Frank fracture which is that this
part of the foot a bunch of soft tissue
damage too two friends mine last two
years have broken their pelvis which is
uh life-threatening I've had a number of
friends become paralyzed breaking their
neck in shallow water hitting the bottom
that's just hitting sand and I do think
once you learn how to fall surfing it's
a lot better than being a skater but
there's there's a lot of potential
injuries Sean Doherty asks why do
surfers always have long hair
foreign
do surfers wear sunscreen most do
I do sometimes not not all the time if
it's really sunny I have dark skin so
I'm kind of kind of lucky I don't get
burnt very often so if I'm not going to
get really fried I don't Sean Kennedy
says what's the biggest wave you've ever
seen I don't know on video probably 90
feet on in real life probably 6 70 70
feet in front of me when I'm surfing
about 50 or 60 feet casual fennec says
where the am I supposed to put my
car keys if I go surfing by myself
um
I hide mine I don't tell you where or if
you have a wetsuit some wetsuits have a
little pocket you could put it in a
little plastic bag and throw it inside
your wetsuit Ed Saunders asks went
surfing for the first time last weekend
and it was awesome question for Surfers
though how do you manage in the sea
without goggles my eyes were stinging
after an hour there's very few people
that wear goggles your eyes just get
used to the Salt after a while I mean I
can swim in the ocean all day with my
eyes open and it doesn't bother me
anymore but I know what you're saying
about the salt it's kind of annoying
Josiah Lake Forest says why do surfers
always look more buff than skaters
um because we are
I don't know no it's really because we
we're paddling we're using a lot of
upper body I'm going to guess that
skaters have generally a lot stronger
ankles and lower body legs knees but
Surfers using the upper body a lot so
it'll probably look a little bigger in
the shoulders and lats and neck
anthonita seven asks why don't Surfers
wear helmets it was never
sort of some kind of accepted cool thing
I think growing up and because of that
there weren't many helmets available and
they didn't modify them to small enough
and comfortable enough to be common use
but they're getting there now they're
getting better I'm starting to see more
guys wear them a couple of my friends
have had bad head injuries in the last
five years and they've started to wear
them Dave shuffles asks to anyone that
surfs have you have you tried web gloves
and do they work as a kid I tried them
yeah they were actually kind of in
fashion for a while in the late 80s
Peter Mel one of the greatest all-time
greatest big wave Surfers from Santa
Cruz last year we got probably what is
the greatest big wave ride in the
history of the world at Mavericks he's
been wearing web gloves when he surfs
let's see if I can get this thing on
yeah so you can see all that space all
this extra space here is covered when
you're paddling I think there's
something to it they look a little goofy
I think people sort of make funnier for
it but you can paddle faster you have
more surface area I feel like they might
come back around they might come back
into fashion Manatee maxcom asks surfing
question
why does Surfers paddle boarders
typo at all put their boards on their
cars thin forward
there's actually a funny debate in
Australia guys tend to put the nose
forward I think the answer is that the
you put the strap right behind the fin
you know so you have your fin there and
you put the strap right behind it so the
board can't slide off backwards sikinosa
asks how to surfing competitions know
the ways will be good that day how do
they plan in advance what if you were
doing a comp and the water was too calm
to do anything I know a lot about this
because I'm from Florida
and we have had a lot of competitions in
my life where the waves were too small
or arguably too small to have a contest
nowadays it's not super common because
we run
at the right season in the right place
so we go to Australia at a time of year
or Hawaii or wherever it's going to be
at the right time of year generally in
winter time where you have more surf we
try to plan around the historical data
and the seasons where those places are
good 313 Tony J asks can you go surfing
with a life jacket that's a good
question and it's actually an
interesting answer you wouldn't go
surfing with a normal life jacket you
might put a kid in one who's just
learning how to surf who doesn't swim
that well or just for safety reasons you
could Bonk your head with the board or
whatever and get knocked out but we
almost all wear an inflatable life vest
in big surf now and that was developed
by a friend of mine named Shane Dorian
eight nine ten years ago now and he
caught probably the biggest wave he'd
ever caught in his life
he fell going down the wave
he got held down for about close to a
minute underwater almost blacked out
that I think he started thinking about
his family a little bit and thinking I
shouldn't be in this situation and um he
went straight from there and started
developing this inflatable vest with CO2
cartridges if you're say it 20 feet deep
and you pull that that'll take you to
the surface much faster than you could
ever swim you don't want to have to rely
on that so everyone trains themselves
breath holding and cardio and and and
getting comfortable in scary situations
but um that has definitely saved a
number of people's lives and allowed big
wave surfing to go Way Beyond what we
thought it could do Chris Grace 7s I
dream of the day when wave pools are as
common as swimming pools and I have
consistent surf in my backyard to ride
my skeet in well I don't know about the
ski but maybe a surfboard yeah I kind of
dream about that too in fact I developed
a wave pool and and we opened that wave
pool in 2015 we worked on the technology
for 10 years 9 10 years prior to that
and and surfing wave pools are quite
common now they're a little bit
expensive right now and they're pricey
to ride but and that's all been being
developed really quickly and there's
probably five different real solid
technologies that you can go and surf
anywhere around the world in multiple
different pools all right that's it
that's all our questions for the day I
hope you learned something I hope it was
useful see you next time